so Apple today introduced a whole bunch
of new products and you know their
yearly introduction of cool apple things
and we finally learned a little bit
about the Apple TV and how that's going
to be integrated into gaming what did
you guys think about what a what Apple
had to show oh it was a very Apple move
to announce the sort of things they did
and and that is sort of these
incremental tech updates that stoke the
interest of fans who are already sort of
bought into the apple ecosystem and and
want to get something new but I'm not
terribly impressed in terms of I think
the growth of that audience I don't know
if Apple is really going to capture
anyone brand new with their updates even
with the gaming stuff on Apple TV which
to me is a little bit late and a little
bit middling well all of the hype around
I'm around this event leading into it
was they were going to do something huge
in gaming and what what it ended up
being was just basically some gaming
functionality on the new Apple TV right
which is kind of light so the games they
talked about was Crossy Road and don't
talk down about crossing run unless I'm
not saying it done let's say it's a web
game I mean great is getting multiplayer
but it's you know it's not exactly a
console killer and that's what some tech
blogs are going out there saying you
know wow they really made these huge
strides into the into this market and
it's going to like really impact you
know the current console manufacturers
but you know their target market for
this is very clearly families you know
they also had that Harmonix game which I
can't recall what the name was or its
meat yes what's beetles in like that and
once again yeah that looked like you
know elite beat agents with you know
some wii functionality you know put into
it right it looks very kind of like
maybe we sports yeah with a rhythm
element yeah yeah but I were you
actually expecting Apple to to try out a
competitor to the xbox or the ps4 like
we've known all along it like that this
is something that's more going against
amazon and the fire TV and that kind of
gaming functionality like to think that
they are going to try to replace
playstation or xbox or even nintendo it
is I think really silly yeah I don't
think that we're ever going to like
you're not come out and say here is our
Apple gaming device that is just
dedicated to gaming I don't think Apple
has an interest in that space at all you
know I think that you know they probably
see you know other things that could
mean a
we spend their billions and billions of
unspent money on and you know gaming is
something that they're not really into
you know what they're really strong
right now in the gaming side of things
though is that ecosystem right so they
have the whole itunes infrastructure
that supports everything that's already
on iOS so you know yes it's not going to
kill the likes of an xbox one or a
playstation 4 but you know it will sort
of like you know extend their you know
their reach in sort of mobile gaming
Apple is making a move into gaming but I
think in our world we get so caught up
in the consoles and the pc that we
forget that mobile gaming is still
gaming for a lot of people i'm going to
hear the word games all i play games i
play Angry Birds so I think apple is
making an appreciable difference in that
market at large yes because of the App
Store but there is a problem with the
App Store is that it does not have very
good curation Apple sort of surfaces
some games that are interesting but
there's also a lot of stuff that appears
that are clones they're low quality
games there's a lot of hidden micro
transactions and I think that's going to
be their biggest problem tapping into
the rest of gaming beyond what they've
already you know captured with the
iphone i think this is a good way for
them to expand that base but they're not
going to be breaking any new ground
elsewhere yeah but it took to be fair
though the apples apples comparison in
mobile is the android store this is the
itunes store in the itunes store is you
know [ __ ] like leaps and bounds ahead of
functionality and you know having that
sort of like quality level yeah yes you
know like there is a lot of sort of like
crap on the iTunes Store but like I tend
to find it a much better sort of like
browsing experience and the creation
stuff is all Apple on that thing so it's
all internal sort of like mysterious
editors that work at Apple basically
choosing like those games and then
that's how you find success on that app
store and what I'm looking through the
app store I'm never looking like to try
to find games myself I'm not just like
going through what are the top flappy
bird type games like no I just look at
the top 100 games top 100 free top one
is paid like which one of these or have
I heard of from my friends and that's
the one I'm going to try out or I just
hear about a game for my friend and
that's the one that I download but from
the curation aspect I think it's
interesting that they're also making a
big push for multimedia which we saw is
kind of something that didn't work for
Microsoft and PlayStation and which
could probably work a lot better for
Apple that
are going to be bringing together stuff
that we see across netflix and hulu and
all those different devices as a way to
to get not just gaming but all of your
multimedia yeah I mean Apple is actually
not doing anything new Nvidia and even
amazon have done a really good job of
offering very similar services if you
look at Android TV actually which in
video is leveraging with its its shield
tablet and other shield devices he uses
great voice recognition which is
something that Amazon tried to do but
Google's elder algorithm is so much
better apple just has the market share
to kind of get those people who are
already into that Apple world to latch
onto this stuff so it's not really for
me very exciting to see this stuff
because those options exist it's only
now just kind of sort of coming to light
because of who Apple is it's a
completely app will move though cuz then
never first move isn't anything in tech
what they do is they come in later with
a shinier UI and you know basically
marker that's so much better than anyone
else can so yeah I mean there are sort
of like other products out there that
are doing the exact same thing that will
TVs trying to do and bringing all these
you know disparate media services
together but you know they could have an
edge there depending on how cool that
you I is actually to to use you know
they could actually you know yell leap
leap far ahead of you know some of the
other competitors right now and one of
the interesting things they're doing is
also with the controller that it's not i
think what we what some people might
have been expecting that this is a is
something more like the Amazon fire TV
which was like had a separate game
controller this is more like a
touch-enabled divide it's more like just
a traditional controller it's a very
simplistic thing so like the top sort of
third of it basically is a touch sensor
and from what we saw that's how you
basically controlled most games so I
think for like Crossy Road it was
tapping to jump and swiping left and
right to move so yeah obviously that in
itself is going to be embarrassed i /
games that they can actually you know
play on an Apple TV I think the most
interesting one was that Warhammer game
that they actually showed off but even
that seemed to be you know pretty much
on Rails and graphically it's really
pretty it's like infinity blade looks
amazing but is not the kind of game play
that we think of as this is the game
that I want to play this is not going to
compete against metal gear solid 4 grand
theft auto yeah and this is yeah just to
be clear that what I'm a game was a full
like foot for the iPhone and the iPad so
yeah I mean
in terms of sort of like visual fidelity
you know apples been doing this for
years or coming up with this big
infinity blade looking thing that they
say you know is console quality graphics
but you know don't really have much of
an impact you know further at then you
know there's the sort of like Apple fans
are already out there I think one of the
interesting things will see is how
Amazon is going to respond to this we
haven't seen a lot from amazon gaming
and we're still waiting to see what is
what's going to happen with like Kim
Swift and all these big developers that
they've had we haven't really seen where
that's going in the gaming space and
this is Apple basically getting a jump
on that from kinda out of nowhere and
that's probably one of the things is
going to be more interesting as we
finish up this year and go into next
year yeah the fire phone is anything to
learn from amazon may have too much
hubris when it comes to their promises
but you know we'll see alright so that's
apple in a nutshell i guess we'll see
what's going to happen
you